[Música]
en el día global de acción por la
justicia climática comenzó en glasgow
una multitudinaria marcha que aspira a
reunir hasta 100 mil personas también
hubo manifestaciones en ciudades como
londres parís y seúl donde le piden a
los líderes que tomen acciones más
concretas para combatir el cambio
climático tenemos reporte desde la
ciudad de escocés a casi un centenar de
personas murieron en sierra leona tras
la explosión de un camión cisterna
muchas de las víctimas fallecieron tras
intentar recoger un poco del combustible
que transportaba el vehículo más de 100
personas también resultaron heridas en
el incidente
nicaragua está a un día de las
elecciones presidenciales mientras el
partido de gobierno de los sandinistas
le piden a los ciudadanos que vayan a
las urnas la oposición promueve la
abstención organismos internacionales
rechazan estos comicios y los consideran
ilegítimos por la persecución a la
oposición
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes y desde seúl estambul
hasta londres miles de personas
marcharon en más de 200 ciudades todo
por el día mundial de acción por la
justicia climática los organizadores de
las protestas le exigen a los líderes
mundiales que asisten a la cumbre
climática cop 26 que tomen acciones
concretas para luchar contra el
calentamiento global por eso en glasgow
que acoge a la cumbre se convocó a más
de 100.000 personas
andrew a amaia nos da un recorrido por
las protestas
día global de acción por la justicia
climática una jornada que manifestantes
de todo el mundo aprovecharon para que
sus exigencias sean escuchadas el foco
de las masivas marchas fue el glasgow
sede de la cob 26 hecha múltiple crisis
es una crisis múltiple pero tiene las
mismas raíces es una economía quebrada
una economía a mañana y nos está
poniendo a todos al borde de la
catástrofe podemos arreglar el planeta y
podemos abordar la desigualdad y la
pobreza globales miles de personas
también apoyaron la causa desde londres
y la explanada de la alcaldía de parís
espero que las cosas cambien haber
venido aquí me hace ver que no soy la
única en preocuparme por el futuro lo
que me da más esperanza
en seguro cientos de personas se pasaron
entre manos esta enorme pelota inflable
en representación de un planeta en
llamas
se está celebrando la convención de las
naciones unidas sobre el cambio
climático en glasgow han tenido
reuniones cada año durante 26 años en la
crisis climática aún no se ha resuelto
dado que esto no se puede detener los
ciudadanos de todo el mundo estamos
saliendo a actuar por nuestras vidas
seguridad y futuro
en estambul los ambientalistas exigieron
proteger el planeta para las
generaciones futuras
y en australia las manifestaciones
regresaron a sídney y melbourne
rechazando la postura del gobierno que
no se unió a las promesas hechas en la
cumbre climática para reducir las
emisiones de metano en un 30% la primera
semana de la cob 26 logró también
acuerdos para la eliminación progresiva
del uso del carbón y acabar con la
deforestación para 2030 sin embargo
activistas de todo el mundo no han
escondido su escepticismo ante las
promesas que denuncian podrían ser de
nuevo una feria del bla bla bla
vamos a áfrica porque cerca de 100
personas murieron en las afueras de la
capital de sierra leona freetown después
de que un camión cisterna explotara en
una gasolinera tras colisionar con otro
vehículo así lo informó el viceministro
de sanidad a marian by otras 100
personas también resultaron heridas esta
gran cantidad de afectados se debe en
medida a que una multitud se reunió
alrededor del camión para recoger el
combustible que se filtraba tras el
incidente aurora valle tiene la historia
la explosión se produjo en la noche del
viernes en wellington un suburbio del
este de la capital de sierra leona según
las autoridades un remolque chocó con un
camión cisterna que transportaba
combustible una gran multitud se
apresuró con recipientes para recoger el
combustible que se estaba derramando
cuando todo explotó el presidente julio
humada vio que se encontraba en escocia
asistiendo a las conversaciones sobre el
clima de la cob 26 deploró la tragedia
estoy profundamente consternado por los
trágicos incendios y la horrenda pérdida
de vidas en la zona de wellington mi más
sentido pésame a las familias que han
perdido sus seres queridos y a las que
han quedado mutiladas como consecuencia
de ello mi gobierno hará todo lo posible
para apoyar a las familias afectadas las
imágenes publicadas en internet
mostraban víctimas gravemente quemadas
mientras el fuego arrasaba a las tiendas
las casas y los vehículos cercanos las
autoridades indicaron que las personas
heridas fueron evacuadas a varios
hospitales de la capital y que
trabajadores sociales estaban ayudando a
los damnificados
intentar colectar combustible es una
práctica habitual en algunos países
africanos incidentes similares cobraron
la vida de unas 85 personas en tanzania
en 2019 y de otras 50 en república
democrática del congo en 2018
en el oeste de india se incendió la sala
de un hospital dedicada a atender
personas que padecen kobe 19 al menos 11
de los 17 pacientes que había
hospitalizados fallecieron todavía no se
conoce cómo comenzó el fuego y las
autoridades afirmaron que realizarán una
investigación el accidente ocurrió en la
ciudad de amenazar amenazar esta clase
de conflagraciones son frecuentes en
índia por el deficiente mantenimiento y
la falta de equipos para extinguir las
llamas en mayo otro incendio en una sala
de pacientes con kobe 19 mató a 18
personas
pasamos a alemania la policía confirmó
un ataque con cuchillo en un tren de
alta velocidad que viajaba entre las
ciudades de regensburg y nuremberg en el
sur del país hubo varios heridos y al
menos tres de ellos están en una
condición grave aunque la policía dice
que sus vidas no están en riesgo el
sospechoso fue arrestado y se trataría
de un joven de 27 años el portavoz de la
policía afirmó que no hay evidencia de
que otros atacantes estuvieran
involucrados las autoridades investigan
este caso como un intento de homicidio
puedo confirmar que tenemos tres
personas con heridas graves aunque según
la información que tengo actualmente no
hay peligro para la vida de estos tres
heridos y gente de creen de los
antecedentes de este hecho porque
sucedió por ahora no es claro y es
sujeto de próximas investigaciones sin
embargo y puedo decir que hay una
sospecha inicial de un presunto intento
de homicidio y se están realizando las
investigaciones al respecto y ahora
hablemos de eeuu en la ciudad de houston
en texas al menos ocho personas murieron
y otras 17 fueron llevadas a los
hospitales ellas resultaron heridas
durante una estampida en el festival de
música a su work otras 300 personas
presentaron heridas leves como cortadas
y golpes el hecho ocurrió cuando la
multitud comenzó a empujar hacia el
escenario cuando el rapero travis scott
presentaba su concierto él detuvo varias
veces el show cuando vio que los
fanáticos de las filas delanteras pedían
ayuda a través de twitter el artista
dijo que estaba devastado y aseguró que
apoya a la policía mientras avanza con
la investigación
lo que sabemos es que aproximadamente a
las nueve en punto nueve y quince la
multitud comenzó a comprimirse es el
frente del escenario eso causó pánico y
comenzó a causar algunos heridos
samper y las personas comenzaron a caer
a perder el conocimiento y eso generó
más palmas coches
el destino de soltar y el presidente de
estadounidense joe biden afirmó que el
plan de infraestructura significa un
gran paso para el país y es que luego de
meses de divisiones internas el partido
demócrata unión sus filas y logró que la
cámara de representantes aprobara el
proyecto de ley este es uno de los
planes bandera del mandatario que
destinará 1,2 billones de dólares para
mejorar carreteras puentes y la red de
internet sin embargo todavía falta que
se apruebe el segundo plan que propuso o
bailén sobre gasto social y medio
ambiente el mandatario resaltó los
logros de su administración en estos
diez primeros meses
ayer no creo que sea una exageración
dimos un paso monumental como nación nos
enteramos que nuestra economía creó 56
millones de empleos desde que llegamos
al poder el 20 de enero una tasa de
desempleo de 46 % dos años antes de lo
que la gran mayoría de los economistas
proyectaron que sucedería las
autoridades de méxico intentan detener
la caravana de emigrantes que ha
caminado durante dos semanas
agentes de la guardia nacional y del
instituto nacional de migración
desplegaron un operativo para frenar a
los migrantes que salieron el viernes de
la ciudad de tonalá en el estado de
chiapas los migrantes fueron obligados a
bajarse de los carros en los que se
transportaban desde el 23 de octubre han
recorrido más de 200 kilómetros
intentando llegar a la capital ciudad de
mexico escuchemos lo que dice uno de los
participantes de la caravana
ellos están abusando va contra la ley va
porque bien sabe de que que la migración
ya sabe todo y que incluso cuando
estábamos en chiapas ellos querían
arreglar los papeles para que la misma
guardia no los detuviera abajo pero
resulta que ellos no han hecho nada y
ahorita que veníamos ahí ellos se
portaron bien violentos con los niños
las mujeres viven que venían ahí e
inclusive golpearon una señora y la
agarraban del pelo y todo a un día de
las elecciones presidenciales el partido
oficialista de nicaragua le pide a los
ciudadanos que vayan a las urnas la
oposición y los nicaragüenses exiliados
por su parte promueven la abstención la
comunidad internacional ha dicho que no
reconocerá los resultados incluso antes
de que lleguen es que siete candidatos
opositores han sido detenidos no habrá
observadores internacionales y el
gobierno prohibió el ingreso a los
periodistas extranjeros sin embargo
rosario murillo vicepresidenta y esposa
del mandatario daniel ortega dice que
los comicios se realizan en paz veamos
en esta serie especial cómo está el
ambiente electoral
la certeza del vencedor una nicaragua
sin campaña política en las avenidas del
país no hay ninguna alusión a las
elecciones generales del próximo 7 de
noviembre la previsión de los resultados
es tal que ni el oficialista frente
sandinista hace publicidad sus
seguidores deben comprarse un souvenir
si desean honrar a su partido desde
antes del 19 lando buscando y no al ayer
y ahora que tuve la oportunidad de venir
aquí y la puedo comparar la compré
enrique núñez consiguió una bandera del
partido sandinista aunque extraña las
épocas cuando el presidente daniel
ortega se tomaba el tiempo para
conseguir votos yo me acuerdo cuando yo
estaba chiquito él llegó una vez a la
intendencia allá del mercado oriental y
yo lo vi persona de persona cara a cara
no como ahora porque cuesta ser barceló
ahí lo tuve yo a la par las elecciones
han causado controversia porque siete
candidatos de oposición están
encarcelados y varios partidos fueron
suspendidos por el órgano electoral para
este politólogo ortega ir a unas
elecciones sin competencia prácticamente
los candidatos
y que todo ha sido colaboracionistas son
gentes desconocidas prácticamente para
el público en general y si por añadidura
no tienen o no hacen propaganda quién va
a ir a votar por ellos
aparte digamos de que mucha gente está
decidida a no votar porque prácticamente
el frente eliminó a los que
desgraciadamente le podían hacer
oposición ortega de 75 años aspira a su
cuarto mandato consecutivo como
presidente su esposa rosario murillo
también busca reelegirse como
vicepresidente del país hasta ahora los
lugares de venta de camisetas y
souvenirs políticos son los espacios
donde se siente un ambiente electoral en
nicaragua el presidente daniel ortega no
necesita invertir en promoción
su triunfo es casi un hecho
y terminamos en brasil porque la famosa
cantautora marilia mendoza murió en un
accidente de avión la avioneta en la que
se transportaba junto a otras cuatro
personas se estrelló en una zona rural
del estado de minas gerais y todos los
ocupantes fallecieron en dos a era una
de las principales voces de la música
con tribunas y leña
[Música]
cinco años de fama y 26 cortos años de
vida marilia mendonça la mega estrella
brasileña de la música country ha muerto
en un accidente aéreo se dirigía a dar
un concierto en caratinga en el estado
suroriental de minas gerais el productor
de la ganadora del grammy latino su tío
y los dos pilotos también murieron la
policía ya abrió una investigación
los restos de una antena sugieren que el
avión colisionó con ella antes de caer
más audiencia
[Música]
con su canción infiel sobre el engaño
mendoza saltó a la fama nacional en 2016
relaciones fallidas y empoderamiento
femenino el tema resultó ser una fórmula
ganadora y lanzó un éxito tras otro
acumulando miles de millones de visitas
en youtube y convirtiéndose en la
artista más escuchada de spotify en
brasil en 2019 y 2020 su amigo íntimo el
futbolista neymar tuiteó que se negaba a
creer lo ocurrido el presidente yair
bolsonaro declaró por su parte que todo
el país estaba conmocionado por el
fallecimiento de una de las mayores
artistas de su generación
además de su legado de ofrecer una
perspectiva femenina en un género
musical tradicionalmente machista
conocido como el ser tan hijo marilia
mendonça deja atrás a su hijo que
cumplirá dos años el próximo mes
[Música]
y nos despedimos de marilia mendoza
hasta aquí nuestro informativo sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24
[Música]